un triste anniversaire pour la famille
d'estelle mouzin il y a quatre ans
disparaissait à guermantes la fillette
âgée de 9 ans les enquêteurs continuent
de travailler sans relâche ce sans pour
autant avoir de pistes sérieuses tout
exploré l'hypothèse de rattacher la
disparition d'estelle à michel fourniret
le tueur en série est écartée à l'heure
qu'il est cécilia douche et celle mouzin
c'est cette petite fille de 9 ans
disparu depuis quatre ans à la sortie de
son école à guermantes personne n'a
oublié cet après midi sa famille
accompagnée de 150 personnes se sont
rassemblées pour connaître la vérité sur
cette disparition
extrêmement dur de savoir comment
progresse l'enquêté il faut savoir un
temps évoqué la piste de michel
fourniret le tueur en série des ardennes
accusé du meurtre de cette jeune fille
semblerait s'estomper le tueur
disposerait d'un alibi sa présence en
belgique au moment de l'enlèvement
d'hespel l'écarterait provisoirement du
dossier il n'y a rien actuellement dans
le dossier concernant l'enlèvement
d'estelle mouzin qui directement ou
indirectement impliqués
michel fourniret cependant il ya encore
des recherches à faire pour s'assurer
qu'il était bien en sart-custinne en
belgique dans son domicile le 9 janvier
2003 après quatre ans d'investigations
les policiers confirment que l' enquête
n'est pas mise en sommeil depuis quatre
semaines le groupe dans quel travail sur
un nouvel axe de recherche